merci eric zemmour d'avoir répondu à nos
questions le jour d'autres de votre
déclaration de candidature à l'élection
présidentielle comme je suis cent mille
merci à vous non je trouve simplement
que il n'y a pas eu de questions sur mon
projet politique et je le regrette je
voudrais inviterait bien volontiers mais
c'était le moment ou jamais je vous
inviterai bien volontiers une partie de
ce que nous avons dit avait trait à
votre programme pas vraiment il me
semble que si il me semble que non merci
vous courrez merci à vous merci olivier
bédard d'être avec nous conseiller en
stratégie politique directeur national
des événements d'eric zemmour pour vous
cette interview hier c'est une honte
c'est une honte cette annonce et s'est
assis un peu gâchée quand même eric
zemmour c'est la première fois de sa vie
que les candidats ont fait passer à
toutes les cinq minutes non donc voilà
il avait envie de parler de ce programme
il n'a pas eu l'occasion de parler de ce
voyage choisi
moi s'il m'avait demandé et il m'aurait
demandé je voudrais ici énorme énorme
quand il va revenir il va venir ici de
façon le 16 mai pour annoncer sa
candidature vraiment je vous le dis je
le lui aurait déconseillé d'aller sur
tf1 parce que je vous le dis on sait que
ça va être ça va être assez partial
voilà donc forcément gilles touré parce
que
c'est tellement tort on sait très bien
que amélie f1 suit la mouvance
présidentielle en ce moment donc c'était
c'était très dangereux d'y aller
c'est pas du
ce et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
fait une annonce de campagne de
candidature par vidéo qui a été vue près
de deux millions et demi de fois sur
youtube
ensuite il allait faire inventeur donc
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
il aurait traité gilles bouleau de
connaître j'ai entendu ça effectivement
alors moi je n'étais pas là avec lui
sarah qui étaient à côté n'a pas entendu
qu'ils sont eric zemmour tout est
possible mais je veux pas confirmé ça en
fait d'accord c'est possible ah bah oui
c'est possible quand on sait le nombre
d'hommes politiques moi j'ai fait vingt
ans que je fais ça le nombre de
politiques qui traite de connard les
journalistes après les interviews
données en paquets depuis toujours
politique
doit-on politique alors une armée c'est
vrai enfin gère le langage un peu dur il
existe il existait avec chirac avec
sarko avec tout le monde
spécialiste
zemmour est en colère il a fait savoir
selon les informations du parisien
coûtant le plateau du jt en rejoignant
la loge où dit il aurait entendu tant
attendu le journaliste de tf1 être
insultés par eric zemmour on précise que
gilles bouleau n'était pas là puisqu'il
continue et la présentation du jt mais
il a dit voilà il a dit que chez le
boulot était et est un connard en
quelques minutes plus tard en regagnant
son qg de campagne dans le 8e
arrondissement de la capitale eric
zemmour a réagi a dénoncé une interview
de procureurs de la part de gilles
bouleau regardez et après on va
remontrer le petit comparatif qu'on a
fait vous voyez toutes les interviews de
monsieur boulot pour tous les autres
candidats vous verrez la différence vous
verrez que devant les autres il s'efface
poliment humblement je dirais même
parfois de façon larvaires et qu'avec
moi il sait il s'est révélé la un
procureur pugnace de mauvaise foi
monsieur boulot n'a pas fait son travail
monsieur boulot a voulu faire le malin
devant ses confrères monsieur boulot
anna n'a pas fait son boulot moi je
connais le travail de journaliste et je
sais ce que c'est et je sais ce qu'il
aurait dû faire et ce n'est pas ce qu'il
a fait vos mots sont forts est ce que
vous regrettez
alors on a fait un petit comparatif
regarder premier exemple avec les débuts
d'une interview le fameux bonsoir vous
allez voir l'intonation du bon soir face
à eric zemmour et face aux autres gardes
bonsoir xavier bertrand bonsoir bonsoir
jean luc mélenchon bonsoir bonsoir exe
noirmont soir gilles bouleau
ou malheureux bas
bonsoir xavier bertrand bonsoir bonsoir
jean luc mélenchon bon choix bonsoir exe
noirmont soir gilles bouleau
c'est génial
c'est voilà qu il n'y a pas besoin d'en
dire plus finir le ton est là qu'est ce
que vous voulez aujourd'hui alors il a
envie de passer à autre chose que ce
genre de moment où quoi voilà on en
vient alors à relais de fond quoi
regarder parce qu'on a un autre on a un
comparatif on a pris les premières
questions de gilles bouleau avec les
autres personnalités politiques et la
première question qu'il a posée à eric
zemmour et voir ses deux salles deux
ambiances vous écrivez dans votre
programme que si vous êtes élu président
de la république vous abrogerait le pass
sanitaire vous l'abroger même avec la
flambée actuelle de l'épidémie
allez-vous passer par le congrès de l
air qui aura lui on le rappelle le 4
décembre prochain est ce que vous allez
vous soumettre au vote des militants
vous décrivez une france en état de
quasi guerre civile
vous dites que vous voulez sauver la
france est ce qu'en faisant cela vous ne
l'exercent crb pas les tensions
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
gilles le vernet très franchement tf1
voulu se payer eric zemmour voilà moi ce
que je pense de tout ça c'est que ça
dépasse même le cadre de gilles bouleau
je cautionne évidemment pas un connard
éventuel mail à l'interview c'est prince
et après je sais apprécier vous est à
l'opposé des idées d'eric zemmour à
total oui je parle et là en tant que
journaliste en tant que juriste de l'
objet télévisuel pas du fond je trouve
que c'était presque indécent c'est à
dire que ça se voyait trop qui avait une
volonté de détruire un candidat et
personnellement c'est une étable non
seulement raté mais que je trouve
partisane donc incohérente alors on a
remarqué aussi que gilles bouleau
d'habitude ils hyper cool avec tout le
monde il fait même des compliments
certains invités à regarder et on sent
que eric zemmour c'est pas trop son
délire gamme vous avez détaillé
l'essentiel de vos propositions dont le
numéro de l'ops qui est à paraître
demain très belle photo vous faites
également une proposition spectaculaire
dans votre programme est ce que vous
pensez qu'une majorité de français 52 1%
pour être élu est prête à voter pour un
homme qui a été condamné deux fois deux
fois pour provocation à la haine raciale
par la justice de ce pays alors ça il
était un peu obligé de lui poser
guillaume et l'interview il était
clairement à charge ça fait des mois
qu'on accueille règlement sur un
programme et sur des mesures concrètes
là il reparle de polémique sur lesquels
eric zemmour s'est exprimé
une fois à succès assure le doigt
d'honneur etc et moi je pense que tf1
ils ont fait exprès de faire une
interview à charge et musclé pour pas
qu'on dise qu'ils puissent donner du
crédit j'en veux c'est retrouver ses
moyens ce qui a eu un petit débat une
petite question je pense tous la
question moi je reçois et rixheim
mais voilà je fais pas je vais pas eric
zemmour même si on n'est pas d'accord
sur plein de trucs je vais pas je vais
faire une interview et je vais faire
cuire voir comme j'ai reçus dont luc
mélenchon ou autre bras je pense qu'on
attend ils se sont dit voilà muscles un
peu l'interview c'est ça qu'on dise
qu'on lui serre la vis exactement pose
question chez eux de recevoir ses mots
alors ce qu'on a reproché également à
eric zemmour hier ce qu'a reproché à
eric zemmour hier c'est qu'on n'ait pas
parlé du tout de son programme alors du
coup on a regardé si gilles bouleau
avait évoqué les programmes des autres
candidats regarder un chapitre important
de votre programme très important vous y
consacraient de longues pages c'est la
lutte contre la pauvreté quelles mesures
importantes prendriez vous si vous étiez
élu président dans ce que vous dites
dans ce que vous écrivez vous laissez
entendre que les femmes sont inférieurs
aux sommes que leur intelligence est
inférieure à celle des hommes
karim
écoutez moi je suis pas choqué
contrairement à vous il n'a pas de
programme eric zemmour non mais on fait
un nom mais excusez moi voulait qu'on
lui pose des questions c'est quelque
chose qui n'existe pas
dix minutes il a quand même dix minutes
d'intentions politiques pendant 52
candidatures le programme il est temps
d'écriture il est validé il est en train
de travailler là quatre mois de campagne
born this way back au mieux que madame
de macron est sorti en parle de rihour
il est sorti ou pas non il n'est pas
sorti avec ses intentions sur les tiques
à pattes à 10 minutes de tête je
relisais le texte qu'il a dit pendant sa
vidéo d'annoncé ne connaît pas les
éléments d'une
question de poser une question l'atelier
doit pas poser une question au niveau et
une cyril qu'un de ses journalistes tu
prépares ton interview si un programme
quelque part tu cliques tu me regardes
et tu as et puis ensuite tu pas des
guetteurs ya pas un seul endroit où on
peut trouver le programme d'eric zemmour
vous me dit d'aller dix minutes de sa
gratitude aux intentions politiques si
je peux me permettre schatz et du
burundi alors il est où c'est un morceau
il aurait pu lui dire ça alors il aurait
pu lui dire est votre programme il ou ok
vous allez refaire ça fait deux mois les
permis sans vouloir de moi qui les modes
de jeu ou zidane shell c'est difficile
pour tous les candidats voilà c'est dur
une capitalisation vous fait pas de
cadeau bienvenu vous avez dit qu'il est
précieux il découvre ici je peux me
permettre il découvre ce que la
politique il a du mal à endosser des
canaux costume d'un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
on vous déroule pas le tapis rouge
emmenez je relis je n'attends pas au lit
et j'ai une brise et les serpents du
crime mais c'est vrai pour deux heures
pas du tout olive & gabbana dont
plusieurs choses hein ça fait deux mois
qui fait des salles pleines ça fait deux
mois alors juste il est une révélation
politique au fond on n'attendait pas
eric zemmour 1 19% au bout de six
semaines ça fait deux mois qu'il a vendu
250 milles bouquin il ya un truc qui se
passe autour de lui à la ferveur moi
j'ai fait la campagne de sarkozy 2004
2005 2006 2007 je retrouve la même
ferveur je retrouve la même tension je
retrouve le même clivage moi je me
souviens d une de sarko est il fou je me
souviens de sarko facho matin midi et
soir j'avais la même chose ils ont la
partie sarko il avait en partie
effectivement et eric zemmour en train
de créer quelque chose alors
effectivement que ça dérange les rentes
de situation des uns et les autres je
comprends qu eric zemmour est clivant
louis mercier l'écrivant parce que ce
qu'ils voient dans ce pays ça ne lui
plaît pas c'est clivant aussi s'il ya
dans ce pays il sait ce qu'ils dénoncent
moi très franchement j'attendais de
cette interview quelque chose d'un peu
plus profond que de revenir sur des
vieux bouquins qu'il écrit il ya 15 ans
et faire l'exégèse sur savoir se mettre
à écrire alors s'il vous plaît vous
grâce à la fusion à la réaction de
gérard carreyrou qui était directeur de
l'info de tf1 avant qui a donné son avis
et regardez il est plutôt d'accord avec
olivier bédard j'ai été choqué hier soir
je n'ai d'ailleurs dit où l'on qui était
avec moi
j'ai été choquée en tant que journaliste
et j'ai été choqué plus particulièrement
en tant que journaliste de tf1 j'ai été
vingt ans à tf1 je n'ai jamais vu une
interview qui est était une interview
aussi déséquilibré alors je le demande
pourquoi où l'eau est un est un bon
journaliste
on avait l'impression qu'il avait
préparé une série de mises pour faire
essayer de faire exploser essayé de
faire exploser mots alors vous êtes
marrant parce que j'étais avec jean
claude dassier cyril avant de venir il
était directeur de l'information de tf1
qui me dit tout le contraire et je n'ai
rien trouvé d'anormal dans l'interview
et laurence ferrari faisait pareil elle
qui a présenté le 20 heures donc vous
voyez que selon les avis et sain d'être
partisan on peut ne pas être d'accord
avec des danses et mouret clairement
frustrés de ne pas avoir pu répondre à
des pénétrations et pourquoi il
n'a pas pris le pouvoir oui moi il n'a
pas dit mary jemâa politiquement
pourquoi il a été bien toujours tout de
boulot
mais olivier pâques tout grand monde
d'accord pourquoi il n'a pas parlé son
biographe pourquoi il a peint poserait
été madiot tout à l'heure à karim tu le
monde ici il avait d'ailleurs décidé
d'endosser le costume de candidat mais
la chaussée est ce que tf1 lui champ de
ses ce costume c'est pratique
mais si les vins interview du candidat
mélenchon j'ai vu une interview du
candidat jadot hier j'ai pas vu une
interview du candidat zemmour j'ai eu
une interview de l'homme on est revenu
sur toutes ces polémiques et sur ceux
des avis sur des sujets qui n'ont rien
avec l'accompagnement de ces planches et
sa douce voulu faire passer zemmour pour
un fou en lui disant voilà regarder mais
vous dites sadefa vous dites ça des
immigrés etc sans s'intéresser au fond
de sa campagne il a le droit d'être
traité comme un candidat il est candidat
mais vous serez pas d'accord avec ses
idées alors que les dominants dominés 2
jours et que vous regardez les au revoir
ce que tu as fait le copinage et au
revoir regardé et on sent que les
interviews s'était pas là sinon paléo je
pense ils vont pas aller en vacances
avec bernard sabbah
merci merci beaucoup xavier bertrand
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
beaucoup jean luc mélenchon votre
message est passé très clairement
mercier m'a répondu à nos questions
concrètes il n'y a pas eu de questions
sur mon projet politique et je le
regrette une partie de ce que nous avons
dit avait trait à votre programme pas
vraiment il me semble que si il me
semble que nous merci vous khoueiry
merci à vous voilà ça va
deux bonjour et merci
va siphonner le contenu goûter pas les
autres merci locaux et berlin karim je
pense que avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour vous et voici une erreur assaut il
a ce côté là thème par un je te le dire
assez des problèmes et des problèmes si
vous faites une erreur fondamentale
c'est à dire que vous êtes considéré pas
que quand il est à tf1 eric zemmour est
un candidat comme les autres mais si
c'est pas une mais si je suis désolé
c'est une émission où il vient après
avoir annoncé sa candidature c'est de
l'information c'est pas de
l'éditorialisation or gilles bouleau qui
est d'une nature assez discrète ilaina
éditorialisé toutes ces questions c'est
que moi c'est ça qui m'a gêné il n'a pas
interviewer quelqu'un à plat il a dans
chaque question ils repris fédération il
a été il y avait des sous-entendus et et
sont abritées sous entendu karim et ça
c'est pas bien vous n'êtes pas bien haut
les oliviers olivier medard juste
aujourd'hui vous êtes content qu'il
s'agisse de déclaré cui là ça y est oui
il fallait le faire sauter une dynamique
parce que la dernière mais un peu baissé
mais des sondages c'est une chose la
fluence qu'on a là on ouvre on a changé
de salle alors joue ce week-end vous
deviez aller au zénith et on verrait au
zénith y avait six mille père s'était
déjà plaint on a on a eu énormément
d'instruction et donc on va villepin que
je viens de ville pas que j'ai passé
l'après midi on a un espace beaucoup
plus grand va pouvoir donc accueillir
beaucoup plus de monde donc on est
absolument ramon places avant alors oui
j'ai pris un espace qui peut aller
jusqu'à 25 minutes d'excellente sécurité
non mais ça compte aussi si on peut
éviter de mettre en danger les gens qui
viennent vu les appels à la violence
qu'on a sur notre public et puis enfin
cesser la chasse à l'homme permanent à
un moment on a aussi besoin de sécuriser
les opérations qu'on fait avec eric
zemmour villepinte c'est une bonne chose
on n'a pas d'objectif mais on avait
besoin de mettre plus que 6000 personnes
et est donc on l'a on va pouvoir le
faire avant de le faire c'est scandaleux
et je vous la violence et scana mais
c'est jusqu'à ce qu'on fait on ne peut
rien faire et qu'on puisse se contredire
sur ses idées sur le mais moi je suis
alors les chouettes allons-y parlons du
fond mais là on est obligé techniquement
vu la ferveur parce que la ferveur on
était parti pour une salle à 5000 en
ukraine 19 mille inscriptions c'est pas
rien donc il fallait changer les appels
il y avait 3000 manifestante déclara est
là avec des manifestants n'ont pas
tranquille de la violence de lentilles
fin des gens qui jettent des objets sur
les gens qui vont au meeting enfin c'est
pas ça la démocratie moi je suis désolé
c'est pas acceptable
on peut pas d'accord mais la violence le
fait de pourchasser ça c'est juste pas
possible donc elles examineront oui les
candidats enfin chouette on va pouvoir
quand même maintenant parler d'eux venu
au zénith
venez l'écouter sa ville une heure de
discours des discours dimanche à
villepinte
pardon j'ai un tournoi mais bon mais
venez je vous invite voilà vous pouvez
vous inscrire sur un zemmour 2022
préfère un autre malgré ceci j'ai tout
fait envie genre tu veux tu veux ya des
toiles peintes alors moi je voudrais
dire d'abord
merci série las donnas merci merci merci
les chansonniers parce que c'est à peu
près avec ma mission sur seignosse
d'être ans que j'ai fait depuis six ans
sur quiconque voyage je dois dire que
eric zemmour a beaucoup de chance il a
toute la presse française au cul depuis
trois mois même si avec ça et remplit
pas léser les salles obscures vraiment
il est très très mauvais partout quoi
qu'il fasse trois heures il fait noir
honneur trois heures ils veulent te
quelqu'un trois heures il n'est pas
content de recharge de 240 heures 3
heures non mais ça de l'état de la
politique française il ya une chose
qu'il faut relativiser beau je pense
c'est qu'il a capté une partie de la
très grande colère que nous avons dans
notre pays d'ailleurs dans l'humanité
qui ne reconnaît plus du tout ces élites
ça il a capté mais pour le reste écoutez
nous ne sommes vraiment pas très
brillant a passé notre temps à commenter
une actualité aussi secondaire
[Applaudissements]
3 j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour jean
lassalle pour une raison simple c'est
que mes grands parents sont morts et
enterrés à pau et mes cousins fondue au
fromage de brebis dans la vallée d'ossau
et adore cela vous est vrai qu'à chaque
fois que je vous entends ça me rappelle
beaucoup de choses plus sérieusement ça
vous vraiment javaux on a on a le droit
de paris mais eric zemmour on a aussi le
droit d'écouter
oui son langage ses analyses sont
clientes manquantes fois quand il parle
de danger pour la france il constate des
zones de non-droit il constate ce qui va
pas et il met le point là dessus il est
un il est un amoureux d'une france qui
l'a connu qu'il a envie de revoir ce qui
est grave c'est parce que dira exe moore
c'est ce qui se passe dans le pays déjà
fait
pardon généralisée beaucoup officialisé
beaucoup et reconnaissez qu'on peut dire
et qui a des problèmes à notre monde
saute pas dire que c'est la faute d'une
commune et un particulier ou une
religion en particulier ou d'une frange
de la population en particulier parce
que là on fragmente le pays une fracture
mais le plan n'a besoin de lauras
amalric car le reglèment il est
fragmenté non si il en rajouter sinon il
la jouera commenté la rentrée d'être un
chien km2 ça
eric zemmour est complètement honnête
avec sa phase 1 c'est un homme était
bleu il absolument adorable déjà son
analyse elle est constante il trouve
qu'elle trouve écho aujourd'hui se
trouve qu'il trouve écho dans la réalité
eric zemmour ne cachera pas les réalités
la france c'est pas disneyland
aujourd'hui franchement il n'a pas là un
moment de la réalité
le monopole de dire les choses telles
qu'il les voit qu'ils aient pensé que
tout le monde le voit d'ailleurs qui
sinon il serait ça ne serait pas à à 15%
aujourd'hui entre anciennes pour ça il
reste 96 % de français qui voteront pas
pour lui et alors aujourd'hui ses
besoins c'est le deuxième podium de
cette élection pression les siens c'est
une nouveauté on l'attendait pas la
nausée femme a alors et c'est pas un
homme policé et il ce n'est pas un homme
c'est justin ville ne sera jamais depuis
depuis hier midi oui c'est devenu un
saint homme politique cei il dit aux
français voter pour moi alors c'est
juste pas la même chose il s'est juste
il est le bras d'honneur aussi eric
zemmour
voilà pris un doigt d'honneur il ya de
ça quelques jours à marseille elle
regarde si demain vous êtes président et
que j'avais un différend sur les ondes
de pêche autour de jersey avec le prêt
ministre britannique est ce que vous lui
ferez un bras d'honneur comme l'avait
fait dimanche dernier j'ai souvenir de
deux gestes de mots de jacques chirac de
nicolas sarkozy et bien d'autres on doit
de 7 et ils étaient des hommes d'état
vous savez je ne suis pas encore
président d'abord mais vous me faites
bien d'honneur et deuxièmement
c'est un geste
on dira pas très élégant mais en tout
cas qui correspondait bien à
l'exaspération de cette folle journée
c'était pas une passante qui passait
c'était une anti fac est arrivé qui a
dit à sécurité je veux lui dire un mot
gentil d'accord il baisse la vitre il
demande à sa sécurité de baisser la
vitre alors qu'elle allait être rejetée
on était quand même sur une 24 heures de
dingue de dengue sur cette journée de
marseille pour chasser
agressé violente et les endroits où il
passait était détruit enfin franchement
c'est n'importe quoi elle arrive il
baisse la vitre et qu'est ce qu'elle lui
dit il faire de l'art en lui disant
casse toi eric est un être humain à peu
près normale il a répondu et vous savez
quoi je pense l'ensemble il dit en fait
se doit il s'adresse à tous les antifas
tous les violents tous les toutous les
dingues qui considèrent que la
démocratie ça peut être ça voilà le le
parcours qu'on a fait à marseille dans
le quartier du panier
les antifas qui avait eu écho du
programme qu'on avait mis sous embargo
pour la presse qui a été donné par la
presse locale à certains antifa on a vu
les captures d'écran arrivée ils sont
passé 24 heures avant nous pour dire si
vous ouvrez on va vous casser voilà ce
qui s'est passé à marseille avec heymans
a duré 15 minutes mais faire une
rencontre avec des gens entre 50
journalistes d'un côté et 200 antifa qui
hurle franchement c'est quoi on va faire
autrement maintenant voilà une seule
roue que vous caricaturez un peu
marseille
lille et islamisés tessin a dit
marseille libin de la face à lui vous
aura des concours vous parler de ça a
payé on n'a pas de frère moi qui parle
de niche mais oui c'est le musée qui
s'est passé on peut être fiers d'être
marseillais c'est la force de marseille
n étant d'origines très différentes je
suis d'euros l'argent les messages pas
excusez moi ne l'a pas priori choristes
mérité mais ses origines sous la garde c
est ce que c'est notre dame de la garde
c'est un lieu sacré à marseille même les
musulmans vont brûler un cierge parce
que c'est un lieu que 1000 à visiter
notre gagnant sur le diocèse n'a pas
voulu qu'il fasse un discours politique
mais j'aurais amercian certain moment il
a été prévu qu'il fasse un discours
politique s'était créé aucun non non
c'était pas prévu je suis au courant
d'organiser bon c'est moi s'est plaint
karim genre de petites questions liées
car non ces prêts immobiliers mais là
sur l'interview avec tf1 est ce qu'avant
l'accord entre alliés à la direction de
tf1 et votre équipe pour que certaines
questions soient posées non pas du tout
non non mais non mais c'est pas vrai
mais il ya toujours un travail d'angle
général voilà quand on se met d'accord
mais jamais on peut de genre eric
zemmour se contrefiche devant les
questions d' avance ces deux sites
isolés de savoir quel est l'enjeu est
surtout le séquençage on commence par un
espèce de cadrage général comme ce fut
d'ailleurs
n'ont pas suivi ils n'ont pas suivi
parce que sinon la
eric zemmour s'est beaucoup préparé à ce
moment puisque c'est un temps portant
pour lui encore une fois on se déclare
pas candidat à l'élection présidentielle
toutes les cinq minutes
c'est la première fois de sa vie qui
fait ça et c'est probablement la
dernière on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
contre parenthèse où l'ours quand même
un parti dimanche c'est pas pour rien on
fait pas ça pour passer dimanche à
villepinte de l'élan à dimanche a mis la
main sur valence à un parti politique
clairement comme un message vous le dire
vous venir en mairie par l'an passé
c'est
que derrière davet que derrick c'est
vrai donc les dimanches on sera le nom
du parti des régions c'est le nom du
parti l'emblème le slogan de la campagne
ça on lance l'ensemble affiche des
anciennes tours fiche de campagne la
faute aux nouvelles dévoilées tout fait
dévoilé seulement des voix de tous ces
partis c'est dimanche pardon dimanche à
villepinte 17000 personnes
j'espère plus maintenant je peux dire
qu'on m'aime savez quoi je je je
le sujet c'est d'ouvrir le zénith à 6000
c'était plus possible c'est d'ouvrir le
plus possible donc moi je dis aux gens
qui veulent venir venez si c'est pas
pour caillasser évidemment le public
mais voilà on fera attention les gens
peuvent s'inscrire je viens
avril dans le cas n'ont pas faibli mais
il y en a ras le bol et une arête
d'exaspération mais non malades et
placez vous traiter de connard
journalistes et
vous voyez vous
ces débris sont des faits moi je suis
bluffé c'est pourquoi je suis pas favori
parce que ça fait deux mois moi j'étais
censé venir pour faire d une tournée
littéraire avec 300 personnes par soir
on en fait 2000
on ne vais pas refaire de 150000
bouquins et on ne veut pas être dans les
sondages à 19% au bout de six semaines
c'est un fait politique alors jean
d'ailleurs le disait parfaitement il se
passe un truc quand même donc
que tout aille contre eric zemmour parce
que oui effectivement c'est un homme
entier ils effraient les frais il est
authentique et je pense qu'elle va
rester authentique et s'il fait des
points c'est bien sûr de la qualité